hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today I'm
probably not gonna accomplish what I've
set out to accomplish because I don't
even know if this is gonna work I've
never done it before I've never even
heard of anybody doing it before and I
haven't found an example of someone else
doing it so I look at today as an
adventure yes we're gonna try some stuff
out I'm gonna do my best to explain and
make this even if we fail I'm gonna try
to make it you know somewhat useful to
you all in terms of you know some of the
stuff that we do hopefully will be
applicable to to your work I'm probably
only going to do one Pomodoro session of
code today because I have a meeting and
I got to get some some data ready for my
meeting so I want to make sure I can
answer all your questions so maybe I'll
do one Pomodoro session and then we'll
spend the rest of the time answering
questions and that should give me enough
time to answer everything so we'll see
how much code we can actually squeeze in
I have a lot of comments already in the
chat which is awesome so let me just
take maybe just a minute no longer just
to say hi and welcome any any new people
it so looks like I'm not gonna read all
the hellos out I'm just gonna just gonna
check I do read all of these so I'm not
missing anybody though there's a lot so
I'm gonna skip over a bed here all right
awesome okay cool
I did have somebody asked how I am so
I'm doing yeah pretty pretty well if
you've been with with stream for a while
you know I'm still recovering from wrist
surgery Marissa actually hurts a lot
today so it's not that bad that I think
it'll really affect my my typing so I
think we'll be fine and this may end up
being my only stream this week because
I'm gonna go to the reactor rally
conference in Salt Lake City and then
I'm going to
straight from there to to New York City
to go to the free code camp Top
Contributor events that they're having
out there so if anybody is in any of
those areas and you know wants to hang
out or something please let me know but
I'll try to like give updates of what's
going on on on Instagram and Twitter and
stuff so I'm not sure if I can get a
live stream man or anything when I'm
there depends on the internet but if you
if you follow me on those social media
platforms then at least I'll be I'll
still be around you know if you have any
questions feel free to reach out to me
okay
okay looks like I'm getting all right
what's going on here somebody says check
the voice can everybody hear me
my mic is showing that it's it's working
where my my OBS screen is showing it's
working let me know also someone saying
about the videos loading okay so I'm not
sure what's up with that let me know if
y'all can hear me and can see me I'm
gonna go into the code now
so I see there's a lot of questions in
there after I do some code for about 25
minutes I'm gonna come back and answer
all your questions
okay so just hang in there let's switch
over so you can see the screen okay so
here's some of the code I have made some
updates and I'll explain more we're kind
of going in a different direction with
the homepage layout so I can explain
that later on if you want and you can
also check out what I've done if you
look at the commit log on the github
repo the the link to that's in the
description to this video okay so today
will mostly be working in this server
j/s file because we're gonna be dealing
with the Salesforce API so I'm gonna
bring over some stuff onto the screen
let me start my Pomodoro timer okay
I'm gonna pull over some of the stuff
that I've been looking at y'all can
check it out and I will paste the links
into the the live chat as well so I came
across this on github and this repo I
know you'll probably can't see it I'm
gonna zoom in here actually let me put
these together and make them a lot
bigger so it's easier for everybody to
see okay so I came across across this
repo it looks like a really old repo but
it has been updated recently a lot of
the files have been updated so I'm
assuming that it it still works we'll
find out but this is gonna allow us to
more easily connect to the Salesforce
API so here's the documentation for that
and right now I'm looking at how to
connect right and so let's go back to
our getting started because we're gonna
start right right at the beginning okay
we can install this right you know just
with NPM we're gonna use yarn because
we've been been using yarn and I'll need
to I'll need to do a little bit on
another screen because I need to put in
my credentials so that's about the only
thing you won't be able to see
everything else I'll try to do here all
right so first let's install js4 and my
goal now in this session is just to get
a connection see if we can connect
where's our code whoops all right let's
pull this over okay so I'm gonna do a
yarn let me make this bigger I'll go one
more size larger here alright so here's
my terminal I'm gonna say yarn
you know what let's do this on a
separate branch because I don't want to
mess anything up in the server file so
let's create a let's do git checkout and
we're gonna do put a be flag on there
and then we're gonna say we're gonna
call this let's say we'll call it
Salesforce okay so I like to do get
check out with a be flag because if I
try to do a git branch create the branch
and then check out I often forget to
actually check out the branch so we're
gonna do this in a branch if you're
using it to do version control if you're
gonna put a new feature in especially if
it's like a major feature or you think
you might be like break something while
you're doing it you generally want to do
it on a separate branch if you're
committing to someone else's project you
for sure want to do it on another branch
so this will allow us to feel free to
break things do anything we want and we
can always switch back to the master
branch and make updates and push that up
too in this case the site's not live yet
but we do have a development site that's
that's out there so I definitely
recommend doing that so now that we have
it on this branch now we can do a yarn
add j/s force my double check that name
J force yep that's it
so that shouldn't take too long and
while that's going we can see how we're
going to bring this in so there is a way
to do this in browser but I'm not going
to do that we have node running we're
going to use node we're going to send
data from from the backend the goal of
this is to be able to send data straight
from our react application from a form
on our react application straight into
Salesforce right now we are sending
people prospective students if they want
to inquire about to get more information
about our University they have to click
a link they're directed to another site
that has a form on it it would be a lot
more convenient if they never had to
leave our site or even click away from a
page if we just had the form right there
on the home page as you scroll down
you'll eventually see it and you could
put in some info I think we'll get a
much higher conversion rate let's say on
our on our inquiry form okay all right
great that's there that's that's in
there now so let me make some space here
for a server jsr sure every J's file is
quite crowded right now so eventually if
we get this to work we'll probably move
it to its own separate file but for now
I'm just going to do it here just to
save some time okay
so let's copy some of this stuff and
paste it up here and I'm gonna change
these Tver the cons okay generally when
you're using es6 right or they call
es2015 it's a newer version of java
scripts and some additions to it when
you're using that you want to use Const
or let in place of there if you're not
sure why and you want to know you can
ask me after
disappointment or sessions over I'll be
happy to explain like why you would use
one or the other
but there's really no need to use their
anymore okay could not find decoration
flower module for jazz fours hmm let's
double check and make sure that this
works I thought I did
whoa maybe it didn't okay let's see
all right got a lot of stuff not working
here
maybe this isn't gonna work hmm let's
check the github repo again and we'll go
to issues and see what's happening 195
issues is actually a lot maybe this is
not really being maintained anymore okay
I mean based on the issues that people
are posting here they've obviously got
it to to install okay let's go back here
I wonder if you have to have a certain
version of node so I'm gonna double
check I don't remember seeing anything
about that okay let's check releases see
if there's any info there all right
tomorrow they just came out with a new
release 19 days ago
all right let's I'm just gonna run your
own again
all right things up to date that's weird
why can't we find J s force I don't
really want to open up my node modules
[Music]
I'm just gonna run this one one more
time it probably won't work but you
never know like it does happen that you
just tried the same thing again and now
it works so we'll give it another go
okay didn't get all these I did not get
all these areas this time
[Music]
I
I'm just gonna let that go for now
because I don't think it's gonna matter
so let's move on then it's good to know
that that they have had a recent release
though I do want to check my time
alright about 15 minutes okay now that
we've gone through the installation
let's go to let's go here and look at
how we connect so I'm just gonna copy
and paste this this part this seems like
it's the simplest way to connect so
we'll try this first
there's a lot of other stuff about ways
to connect not worried about it right
now
okay so we definitely need
okay so it looks like all we need to put
in here
hmm yeah all we need to put in here is a
login URL a username and a password okay
cool so I can just put the login URL
right in here and that's not going to be
a problem the username and password I'm
gonna save as environment variables and
then pull them in and so I don't show my
my password everybody okay so first
things first and this would be easy
what is this anxious peek let's get that
that login URL so it says let's see
alright I'm not even sure where let's
see where this is logout this should
take me yep oh yeah so I believe this
would be the login URL and then for a
username and password I am going to open
up the environment variable file on
another on another screen so I'm gonna
pull this over to my other screen and
okay it'll just take me a second to
navigate there
it's not let me open this see
all right I wonder if I can do I not
have a dot end and so weird
because I thought I had one
see
and so weird
okay then I guess I will try to make one
okay
for some reason Digital Studio code does
not want to let me open this project
twice
let's
just making em file and I will drag it
over to my other window there we are
okay now we'll go back here close this
here and I'll say
okay so on my other screen I'm gonna go
to LastPass and find my username and
password
and my username
okay
all right and I should be able to bring
these in in the same way that that these
are being brought in so let's just copy
this save a little bit of time here and
let's make this use your name and I
called this username and then we'll copy
and paste this and change it to password
okay
all right so see we're doing all right
so what we're looking for hopefully is
that we will get some stuff loved to the
console okay
also you should probably check to make
sure we haven't crashed anything all
right it looks like nothing is crashed
on the side so that's good
we can check
yeah
oh you know what let's let's quit that
and let's do a oops let's say sorry I
had a check out I just run us like this
let's do node server yes
we're not getting anything in our
console
you know what let's check our
documentation this
about five more minutes I'll get your
questions so I see there's a ton of
stuff in the live chat so I'm I'm gonna
get to everything all right well let's
see let's assume that we've made some
sort of connection and let's go down and
see if we can make a query now
he
trying to find one that would work with
what data we have
I also don't want to get any data that I
should not be showing what you do oh how
about let's just try to create something
and then I don't have to actually show
anything
[Music]
all right let's try this
I'm not sure if I'd need to put this
inside of here or not we'll try it
inside first oh yeah let's just show
this as is why is it saying this
indentation okay
I do I'm gonna see
make sure I'm just gonna go through kind
of each step just to make sure things
are getting picked up correctly
you know what I'm not automatically
restarting the server since I I just did
this okay alright so we're getting
undefined here and now we're getting an
invalid username password security token
okay all right that makes sense why it's
not working
all right so what's up with this thing
Oh what I did
you know what let me
let me move this over to my other screen
just quickly and I'm gonna I'm gonna
hard code those values directly into the
file I need to do it on my other screen
obviously because I can't have anybody
seeing that but I just want to make sure
you know what the the real problem is
here I mean if we've done all the
Salesforce stuff correctly and it's just
something weird going on with a dot n
file then I I want to know so I don't
spend my time trying to troubleshoot the
wrong thing so my 25-minute timer just
ended so this would be the last thing
that I try okay
I'm gonna say that
let's restart the server see what
happened
Oh user must use security token okay
all right so I need to get a security
token from Salesforce and then you add
that to my password okay what do y'all
think let me know should we try that
just see if we can get it to work or
should I stop now and go to the
questions
I reset my security token I sent one of
my email address okay so I just reset
the security token and they are emailing
it to me if it doesn't come in my email
like immediately I'll just try this a
different day nice it just got here okay
and add it to my password so I'm
assuming I could just paste this right
at the end of my password so that's what
I'm going to do
all right we'll give this one more try
what I'm pretty sure this just works
so we created these records
nice I wonder if I can now search for
these records by ID so let me go and I'm
logged in to Salesforce on my other
screen I'm gonna see if I can search for
a record let's see
I don't know what they have under
normally it's Leeds but I'm not sure if
they use that that terminology
so it obviously it looks like it worked
I'm just not entirely sure where where
it saved this to maybe so normally in
Salesforce you'd use it for a business
and then there would be you would call
them leads but we usually do students so
I wonder if this guy's saved as a
student so sorry I can't show you all
this I don't to accidentally show you
student information so I'm just trying
to do my best to describe what what I'm
doing on my other screen if I get to a
point where I can show you I will
definitely do that let's see if I can
search search students record ID
all right so I don't think it's that
so what I'll probably need to do is I
will need to do a little bit more
reading to see like where by default
does this stuff show up since I'm not
seeing it
oh wait a second I found it
all right cool now I have something I
can actually show you let me move this
over here okay so check this out
so evidently it by default goes to
schools and it it maybe schools
okay so I'll have to figure out how to
put it in the right spot ideally we'd
want these to go into students right but
this works for now so you can see we
gave it the name of my account one in my
account too and so obviously it didn't
fill in these things right because we
didn't tell it to fill these in but you
can see by the owner alias is it's me
just the first part of my name jwu WG
okay so awesome that worked we're able
to connect and we could see like here's
the the ID right of a so very cool
really cool all right awesome so now I'm
gonna go to I guess I'll just let me
switch it up here and now I'm gonna go
back to the chat I'm gonna start way up
at the top and I'm just gonna work my
way down here so I'm gonna try to get to
all of the questions I think this was
definitely a success in terms of you
know we were actually able to add a
record that's awesome now it's just a
matter of figuring out the details of
being able to add it as a student and
get
the right match up the right values so
I'm feeling really really happy about
that and I can't believe it only took me
to me like less than an hour for people
who have watched this stream before you
know this is a rare occurrence that
everything goes like how I wanted it to
go then quickly okay Steven says Jesse
thanks for looking at the landmark site
that floorplan pop-up build was a huge
speed boost for us build wise Oh awesome
yeah that site was amazing
so it was like Bri was really cool I'm
really glad you shared it with me
Nicky says just dropping by to say hi
hey a big order sorry you couldn't stick
can't stick around but thanks for
dropping by
nag nag Indra asks for an angular
project
I don't know angular so I can't really
do an angular project but we do have
some videos of people doing angular
projects I don't think they're live
streams but check the the video list for
free code camp maybe do a search for
angular I know we've had some people do
angular before somebody asks what I what
am I gonna do I'm not gonna answer that
because obviously you saw what I was
going to do so microstrip says hi from
Turkey hey how's it going thanks for
watching Louise says hi hello from
Guadalajara Mexico awesome
Loveland with people from all over the
world John Doe says bonjour from France
oh TSM says 81 says hello from a noob
from Colorado
how's it going I'm a noob from Ohio
originally from West Virginia MLB says
you're looking awesome
superb thank you I appreciate that
not sure if you're talking about my coat
or my face but either way I appreciate
it
somebody commented on one of my recent
videos I think on my last video
something like react Jas is so ugly and
I thought react yes is probably not ugly
it's probably just my code right I'm
sure there are people out there that can
make it look pretty - says what about
UJS I don't know view one it would be
cool one day to try view out but for
right now my projects are done in react
and it would have to be a side project
like I'm it doesn't make sense for me to
do one project in view for work when
like everything we're creating is all
react so we can reuse components that
so but I'm open to doing a side project
with you but it would have to be
something really basic because I've
never used it before we do have some
videos above you so you know again if
you go to free code camp videos do a
search for review you know you'll find
some some view tutorial videos and
things John Cortez says I'm new to
coding I may not get what you'll be
talking about but I'm here to learn as
I'm changing my career to become a coder
awesome awesome congratulations on the
on the career change and yeah feel free
to ask any questions if I'm kind of
skipping by things too fast just you
know ask me I'm more than happy to
explain you know anything Murillo says
is it worth it to learn about canvas it
depends on what you want to do I mean
there are some instances where canvas is
the right thing to use but there's like
I personally never use canvas I've never
come across a use case where canvas made
sense for me to use so and and I've been
a developer for like over five years now
so I would say don't just learn canvas
if you don't have to use it that would
be my advice if you come like Figg learn
what canvas is and what it's good for
and then leave it at that so then that
way if you ever have a situation where
canvas would be good at least you'll
know that you should use canvas and then
at that point you can learn more about
canvas I mean if you have a lot of free
time and you really just want to learn
canvas and you know go ahead but I don't
think it's it's necessary
all right John Cortez is coding boot
camp worth it it can be it so it kind of
depends on what kind of learning you are
for me I just I was always working and
learning at the same time I never had a
period of time where I could dedicate
all my time to a coding boot camp so I
when I started when I shifted my career
into being a developer I already had a
wife and kids and a mortgage payment and
I so I couldn't full-time like learn I
just learned what I needed to do to get
the job done for my clients so a boot
camp was kind of out of the question for
me at least like an intense boot camp so
I did more like online courses a lot of
free stuff a lot of just learning on my
own
but some people they thrive in that boot
camp setting and they learn a lot
quickly so you have to know yourself
they're also not all boot camps are the
same some boot camps aren't really that
good so you got to you know do your
research and you know figure out like do
you have the time for the boot camp the
money for the boot camp is that your
learning style and then is that
particular boot camp good so it's not
really a question that I could I could
answer in general you know
as act acts says sorry I miss print
might be mispronouncing that says teach
us how to code using mobile please we
did do some streams using react native
to code things for Android and iOS I'd
love to get back to that at some point I
just need to get this project launched
I'm gonna be honest with you this is
gonna be even once we launch this it's
not going to be finished you know
there's always going to be more things
to do and to update but I would love to
shift it so that our main project moves
to something else for this dream
potentially maybe a react native project
and then I do a lot of the work for this
project right now kind of off the stream
and I only come back to it when we're
gonna add like some cool feature that I
think you all be interested in MLV says
how much do you code in 24 hours oh it
just depends it depends on the 24 hours
so there have been times when I've I've
worked for like 14 hours like if I have
to launch a project and there's a lot of
stuff to do sometimes it's I've coded
for that long before that's pretty
extreme and obviously there are some 24
hour period so I don't cut it at all but
running in an average maybe like an
average would be like 5 hours a day or
something I don't know because I don't
spend all day coding I answer emails I
do paperwork I go to meetings so it's it
kind of depends
MLV asked about the github dark theme
yeah if you just type in github dark
theme on google it'll be the first thing
they'll come up just follow the
instructions and yeah it's not it's not
difficult I think there's several
options for getting it toward to also as
we want we wanted to know more about
yourself let me know what specifically
do you want to know I mean I can tell
you a lot about myself but I if there's
anything in particular let me know and
then I'll answer that once I get down to
the bottom there MLB says what's your
skills front-end or back-end
so my title is front-end developer but
realistically I'm more like full stack
now to be honest I say I probably do
more front-end and back-end but we don't
have somebody that's back-end so like
node stuff is back-end stuff right I do
that I set up servers right I set up
Linux servers I'll do the maintenance on
those servers I set up databases right
so all that stuff I do as well so I'm
definitely not purely front-end it just
worked out that that's the title that
that I had because at you know at the
time it was I was mostly doing front-end
stuff so sorry let's just you know let's
go with run it
John Cortez asked about my application
for coding and I was using Visual Studio
code
and Alby says does anyone have a slack
workspace for coding help I don't know
do we have a slack Channel I'm not sure
we've had some channels like chat
chatroom things and but I'm gonna
they're not really that active but if
anybody knows of some sort of like slack
channel for coding help you know
please let em I'll be no
let's see John Cortez says is what Jessi
is doing now something that can be
learned within that three-month boot
camp maybe it depends so Michael had a
good answer says if you're starting from
zero javascript knowledge it might take
a while to build up if you have
knowledge in JavaScript you should be
able to pick it up yeah I I totally
agree with that answer yeah if you're
starting from zero it's gonna be hard to
get here in in three months I'm not
saying what I'm doing is spectacular or
anything but it just it takes time you
know to get to there so yeah but if
you're already good with JavaScript then
it's just a matter of learning how to do
things with react yeah three months is
definitely reasonable and it's hard to
say sometimes it depends on the person
you know if you're like a genius who
knows what you could do
so John says should I drunk Cortez says
should I concentrate on learning HTML
and JavaScript yeah for sure if ya start
out if you go to the free code camp
curriculum so if you go to free code
camp org and you start the curriculum
that's a good place to start go through
it'll teach you about HTML CSS and then
it'll get you into JavaScript and it'll
ease you in you know so you you get you
know that knowledge builds and then you
work your way up and the more difficult
things you'll learn a little react so
that's kind of a good path to go and
then you can supplement your learning
with with other materials
Michael said this seems like it should
be factored out yo yeah for sure
I think it should be too
our m40 says what is that program that
you use I'm assuming you're talking
about Visual Studio code
Michael asked what's the graphic on my
mug okay so here's my my mug so this is
it says fatherhood the best job you'll
ever love so and then on the back here
it has st. Joseph holding baby Jesus and
Mary taking a nap in the background so I
don't remember who got me this mug but I
work at a Catholic University so it's
definitely appropriate I think I got
this like when I first became a father
so my oldest is nine years old so I've
had it for a while you but in case you
don't know I have four children joy
chinam it's Jay a inam please let me
know if I'm pronouncing that wrong I
want to get it right but anyway says
what is the Salesforce API the
Salesforce API is just a way to get data
from Salesforce and put data into
Salesforce by making what API calls
right so you make like an HTTP request
and you can use the the API let me know
if I need to explain that a little bit
more so it may not depending on your
level of understanding right now I may
need to explain a little bit more so I'm
happy to do that if you need me to kendo
says hello from Japan hey how's it going
you know I rarely get viewers from Japan
so that's really awesome thanks for
letting me know
Moo Sadiq says what is code igniter
framework developer code igniter is I
believe code igniter is PHP I think it's
a PHP kind of like framework or
something so from what I understand it's
it's kind of old but I I haven't used it
I a colleague of mine has used it before
and that's the only I
just remember him talking about it
[Music]
Ivan says hi can you show how to hide in
show content text in HTML with buttons
thanks in advance Congrats from Bulgaria
well hi and welcome if you want to show
and hide text in HTML buttons you could
depend on what you want to do right you
could use just overall like you would
want to use JavaScript to tell when that
button gets clicked and then when that
button just clicked you could change the
CSS of that button to use you know to
show our high so it would be like
display:none or display:block you could
toggle that if you were using and you
could use jQuery for that you could use
vanilla JavaScript if you were using
react you would want to change the state
on a button click and then you could
just render it based on like if the
state for this equals true render it
otherwise don't render it right so
there's different ways you could do it
it kind of depends on what what you want
to use so I mean that's kind of a big
overview for that if you want to know
like specifically what code you would
type you know your best bet is probably
just don't check in Stack Overflow or
something
because it does kind of depend on what
you want to use Stephen says every
feature you do is cool hashtag height
thank I appreciate that Bogdan says hi
can I become in six months of junior
developer oh yeah for sure I mean
obviously it depends on how much you
know now and you know how quickly you
can learn things but I think it's
definitely possible in six months
Michael says I didn't realize you shut
up servers too
you really need to get a title change
yeah yeah I guess I should I hasn't I
don't even remember when I got this
title to be honest with you so maybe it
has been a while maybe
I should try to get a change we'll see
maybe I'll wait until they give me like
employees to work under me and then I'll
then I'll go for the title which means
microchip says I know how to learn
programming but I don't know what to do
I need an idea also I'm too used to
Visual Studio code this program perfect
an atom or sublime I'm not sure what
you're asking saying you don't know what
to do you need an idea so are you saying
you don't really have an idea of what to
build or what's it what's a make if you
just Google like app ideas there are
websites out there that give you a ton
of like ideas of things to build so
those will give you some ideas also I
like Visual Studio code I never use
sublime I did use Adam and I switched to
Visual Studio code
I think Visual Studio code is a bit
faster than Adam but Adam is still good
I I used it for years so I think either
one would be a good choice I just I
happen to prefer Visual Studio code at
the moment oh Michael is confirmed that
Cody miter is PHP based
okay so Ivan says yes to do the
show/hide thing in JavaScript yeah if
you wanted to do it and just plain
vanilla JavaScript you know jQuery you
know react to anything like that then
you know you're gonna be using I mean I
guess off the top of my head like you're
gonna be selecting elements with
document dot get element by ID you want
to grab the IDS and then with the click
is so you would need to get like a click
handler right if I'm assuming or click
the buttons and then like depending and
I think I can't remember what is vanilla
JavaScript way for changing CSS but
that's how that's how you would do it
you would use JavaScript to change the
CSS
I mean potentially you could completely
add or remove those elements from the
page but I don't know that I would go to
all that I would I would probably just
use display display:none or like michael
says you could do visibility hidden too
if you want that would also work
the only thing about visibility hidden
is if your your text takes up space and
you do this ability hidden like that
space will still be there you just won't
see the text if you don't want that
space there then you want to do
display:none cuz it'll totally you know
take away any space that will take up
correct me if I'm wrong about that but I
believe that's that's how that functions
gia says is this project nearly finished
how do you think how long do you think
it's gonna take
I hope we're nearly finished I mean I
we're very very close to being able to
launch I'm talking like within a matter
of weeks we can we can launch for sure
maybe maybe sooner I mean I I just have
other stuff going on that I can't launch
it so if I had all my time to dedicate
to it we could
launched next week but I don't yeah so I
mean in terms of launch pretty soon in
terms of finished it's never gonna be
finished this is gonna be the thing that
I'm constantly working on and updating
so you know this is just like this
project is basically gonna be a big part
of my job now from here on out I'm
constantly gonna be updating it
kendo says what are you using for SEO
for react should I be using something
like next Jas yeah if you need to worry
about SEO which is search engine
optimization I definitely recommend
using something like next Jas it doesn't
have to be you just need to server-side
render your code otherwise search
engines are not gonna be able to pick up
any of the the stuff that you're trying
to pull in from an API so the API calls
usually take too long if you're trying
to do a client-side and the search
engines won't stick around long enough
to actually see that that day to come in
so you you want a server-side render so
that when someone first goes to your
site they get just regular HTML all the
constants there and then when they start
clicking around and it's client-side
routing happening then you know that's
cool you can you can do stuff on
client-side so I personally I like doing
both this is kind of a best of both
worlds you get that speed of client-side
routing you know but you also get that
really quick initial load that's search
engine friendly
so next Jas takes care of a lot of the
the background stuff of making that
happen for you so I do I do like using
next jazz for that
michael says how do you get free code
camp projects on github you just have to
you know make a github account and
create a new repo and then do your
project so I'm not sure how familiar you
are with git and github so you might
need to maybe do a course or read up on
that first mmm sorry
yawn I always yawn during the streams
today hasn't been too bad I've been
fighting holding back of the yawns -
Shaw says can you recommend some
projects for intermediate programmers in
PHP I I don't really know I would
recommend again like just googling
project ideas my PHP project ideas cuz
there are a lot of them out there and
you probably get a nice big list and
just pick pick the ones that you like
Michael creo says on click so my career
says create a CSS class to do the dot
add class on click cool
thanks Mike that's straightforward
enough right
[Music]
mmm it's EMRI so I'm not sure to
pronounce that says I bet I have coding
experience for two years and I know C
and C++ so how much time to learn
JavaScript CSS and HTML and I'm from
Turkey
well hello this is the second person
they said they're from Turkey so welcome
yeah if you already know C in C++ I
don't think it's gonna be that difficult
to pick up a new language because you
already have all those new programming
concepts down right you know your basic
things are like like arrays loops like
the concepts of what is a variable like
all those things that seem really easy
once you pick them up you know to a
total beginner it's it's difficult to
you know did
wrap your mind around that so you're
already starting at an advantage so I
like it I can't really say it'll take
this long because it just depends like
how many hours a day do you have how
quick can you pick things up like
there's just a lot of factors but I
think you'll have a much easier time
then then you know someone else you know
who doesn't know about programming
machine says is there some tool to
transpile jQuery into plain old
JavaScript so your clients don't have to
download an extra file I don't really
know that would kind of be a pretty
useful tool though but I don't I've
never heard of anything like that
existing I don't see why I couldn't
though I mean if we can transpile you
know newer versions of JavaScript back
to es5 I guess they could do the same
thing for jQuery but but to my knowledge
it doesn't exist I've never heard of it
John Cortez says thanks for answering my
questions looking forward to watching
more videos Aloha and Mahalo from Los
Angeles I'm so glad that I could be of
some service to you and yeah definitely
I hope you can join again for some some
live and more live chats and stuff and
yeah feel free to keep asking questions
and let's see Dante says I am I am dan
from Kenya enjoyed the enjoying live
feed really learned a lot how can I
improve my react skills really just
practice right I mean it it doesn't hurt
to read up on documentation and like
watch tutorials and things but this
thing that's gonna help you to get
better
the quickest route is just keep building
try every day if you can to just build a
little bit work with it and then you
know as like the little things and react
and the syntax the way to do things
become like natural and you just have it
in your mind all the time
then it'll free up that brain power too
thinking like higher level of I'm gonna
do more advanced things right and you'll
start to build up on that and you'll get
better like like that michael says after
a year of watching you I think I finally
started to feel like I know what I'm
talking about maybe sooner or later I'll
actually apply for a job well I'm glad
that I could get help in that way yeah
and go for it go for for a job you know
to get a job in coding all you need to
do is convince somebody that you can do
it okay you know and then you're ready
and you're always gonna learn on the job
and anybody that's hiring a developer
that knows what they're doing will know
that they're not hiring you because of
what you already know they're gonna hire
you because of what you're gonna
continue to learn because things just
change too fast right you even if you
find somebody that knows everything that
you want them to know and a couple
months it's gonna be outdated already so
that's the that's the key so don't worry
if you don't know everything yet as long
as you can prove that that you know what
you're doing and that you can learn
quickly that's that's what people want
or at least that's what they should want
if they know what they're doing
don't they it says plus how much do I
need to have in my portfolio to get at
least a junior for an imposition I don't
know if there's really you know a number
but you know I would say you know have a
few prize so it's better to have maybe
like three good projects that you've
actually finished and built then you
know like a dozen projects that that
aren't really great and that you never
finished right it's way more
impressively able show somebody
something that actually works and looks
nice
okay so quality is I think more
important than quantity here so that
would be my advice I mean personally
from having reviewed resumes to hire
developers before you know I I wasn't
looking for have you done a million
projects you know I wanted to see I
could look at one project and if it was
a big project and it was
good like that's that's proof right so I
would try you know like more than one
would be good I'm thinking like at least
three would be nice
showcasing maybe some different skills
but don't go crazy it with a lot of
projects unless you have time to really
do them well see John Hanson says when
refactoring a function and react and
reffing state written Const equals this
state returns all states and component
returns only a state why I'm not sure
you know what we ran into some issue
with this recently in a previous stream
I'm not sure how to describe it and what
language to use but that a similar thing
just happened so I'm sorry I can't
explain why it happens like that I just
I got it to work and I never looked up
why so if anybody else knows I guess how
to explain why bad happens please put it
put it in the live chat kendo says how
do we know when these livestream start
probably well number one subscribe to
free code camps YouTube channel and make
sure you turn on notifications
occasionally I do stream on my personal
channel there's a link in the
description if you subscribe to that you
know you'll get notifications from that
as well you can also follow me on
Twitter and or Instagram I usually put
before I I almost always notify
everybody on both of those platforms
before I do a stream so those are the
main ways to know whether or not I'm I'm
gonna do a live stream to sources how to
improve problem-solving skills do
problems write solve problems the
practice is definitely way to do it
there are some techniques so you could
read up on techniques on how to solve
like coding algorithm challenges and
things so it's like some systematic
steps so definitely try that but I think
the most important thing is practice try
to do an algorithm challenge like once a
day you know just start out your day
with you know an algorithm challenge and
you know make sure you get that
practicing boot school says I just
wanted to thank you for your time
are you welcome I appreciate you saying
that MLV says are you front-end or
back-end developer yeah
I don't know I guess the most accurate
right now would probably be full stack
if I do more front end than back end and
my official title is front end but it's
not exactly accurate MLB says parcel
versus web pack what Bill tool is good
i've never used parcel i use webpack i
like web pack i don't mess with
configuring web pack myself though I
always use like the pre-configure stuff
with either create react app or next j/s
but I just I I can't really comment on
parcel because I haven't used it MLB
says what is your YouTube channel check
the description of the video I have a
link to it in there
I can't it's Jessie why if you look up
Jessie why go on YouTube it'll come up
okay Michael said that that issues of
the issue that John Hansen was just
talking about it was on my last stream
that I had that a member says thanks for
answering my questions and which should
I start simple JavaScript or JavaScript
frameworks like react angular what do
you think which is best for me it start
with some simple JavaScript before you
move into a framework so you don't have
to go crazy and learn everything but
it'd be good just to get some of the
basics down the syntax you know and
before you jump right into a framework
so you know that's my advice
if you're gonna start like taking on
clients and stuff and you need to use a
framework then you know go go for it you
know it's it's not like it's gonna
really you know hurt you as long as you
continue to just keep learning as you go
ZX says did you ever make
voice-activated programs like zappy
speak I did do an Alexa and Amazon Alexa
skill before so that's kind of the only
thing that I've done that's
voice-activated and it was really basic
it was just a like a trivia quiz you
could ask it to give you trivia it was a
trivia quiz with trivia from my hometown
so it would just give you a couple of
different facts about my hometown
MLB says should I use any CSS framework
these days I get it depends like if
you're doing react I really like
material UI if you're just doing some
plain JavaScript stuff or jQuery stuff
maybe you want to go with bootstrap if
you like material design style go with
materialise
some other good ones that I've never
used but I heard are good or like
foundation what else I said Karen it's
been a while since I've I've really
worked with any of those yeah but I mean
you don't have to use a CSS framework
but it definitely saves a lot of time
MLB says how much JavaScript I need to
know to understand react you definitely
need at least the basics of JavaScript
it's understand react so the more
JavaScript you know the better you're
gonna be with react so you don't need to
know everything but you definitely
better off learning more okay so Stephen
says learn JavaScript first I'm about to
start react myself I have a friend that
is in a react move camp that knows no
JavaScript and is struggling hard okay
yeah definitely want to know some some
of it michael says no I was making a
joke I don't I don't know where that was
that when was that
I don't even remember what it what it
was they were you making a joke
hey JavaScript is here what's up MLB
says is Marin stat good for 2018 so
marsac is what [ __ ] Express react note
is that it MongoDB I think that's mine
stack it stands for that so yeah I mean
I think mine stack is still valid for
sure Tushar says do you also work with
react native is yes then with Expo or
plane react native I've done both I
prefer using Expo because it's it's
pretty easy to you know get it going on
an actual phone like and see the results
so I I do like using Expo but I have
done both okay so I'm Alvey says yeah
burn sake as [ __ ] Express react node so
MongoDB for your database Express
Express is like a a node plugin to help
run like your back-end with this node
being JavaScript running server-side and
then react would be which you used to
build your app and the stuff that the
client sees right MLB says do you use
Facebook yeah I am on Facebook if you
want to follow me on Facebook feel free
I just don't really ever post anything
okay alright let's see what time it is
oh okay well I just got to the end of
the live chat and I have to go to a
meeting in a few minutes so I'm gonna
finish up here I I don't know if I'm
going to be able to stream until next
week so if I guess have a great week
everyone I'll try to give some updates
on Twitter and
Instagram from my conference and yeah so
thank you all so much for joining me all
the discussion was really great and yeah
so I'll miss y'all
hopefully I get to get to interact with
some of you on social media this
upcoming week but so until then have a
great day have a great week and thanks
again